encarnada como la ciudad que nunca
duerme
nueva york- es ahora una megalópolis
casi desierta con el regreso del
confinamiento y el cierre de miles de
tiendas 'times square' presenta más
animación en sus pantallas gigantes que
en las aceras
y en la capital que aloja walls fitz el
corazón del distrito financiero la
factura es alta para los comerciantes
mukhtar hammett que dirige una tienda de
recuerdos debe su superviviencia a la
buena voluntad del propietario del local
el alquiler no se ha pagado desde marzo
ovelar y nuestro ordenador está de
acuerdo nos hace el favor para que
podamos sobrevivir eso es lo que nos
hace seguir adelante pero muchos
propietarios no cooperan desalojan a
mucha gente
mi amigo de al lado que es chino tuvo
que cerrar y perdió su depósito de 100
mil dólares por ser nueva york la ciudad
de estadounidense que más sufrió la
llegada de la pandemia en la primavera
ha resistido hasta ahora bastante bien
la segunda ola y se encuentra entre las
menos afectadas de norteamérica pero la
tasa de casos positivos del 3% durante
estas últimas semanas bastó para
ahuyentar a los turistas según poses de
este gremio el número de extranjeros de
vacaciones en nueva york ha caído un 66
por ciento en 2020 y eso después de diez
años consecutivos
en la ciudad esta pandemia ha diezmado
cada faceta de nuestra industria afecta
a todas las grandes instituciones al
sector de la hostelería pero sobre todo
a las pequeñas empresas las pequeñas
empresas se han visto particularmente
afectadas por estas el alcalde ya
anunció que nuevas restricciones como el
cierre de gimnasios y restaurantes
podrían volver a aplicarse mientras
tanto el silencio sigue reemplazando al
habitual bullicio por la multitud de
gente